[Music]
not having the yellow text opening crawl
is the new black but still reading how
omniscient are these opening titles
supposed to be normally they're
essentially biographical telling us
about the status of the rebellion or the
fine details of trade agreements and
their impact on intergalactic
legislation but it's telling us what's
in the heart and mind of honking Sola I
don't think even Han knows what's really
in the heart and mind of Han Solo in
this movie
adding a Star Wars story to the end of
this film's title is really infuriating
like we need to know that Han Solo was
part of the Star Wars universe or maybe
they were concerned about being confused
as a reboot for that be Mario Van
Peebles cyborg movie Mario Van Peebles
dice the dice that have been so goddamn
important to all the movies up until now
this is what five six hundred credits
that's more than you said we'd need to
buy our way out of the control so oh you
guys are just reminding each other you
both already know expositional
aspiration exasperation lady Proxima is
a prong basically he spends her time
under water and only emerges in this
dramatic fashion when business requires
it I can totally see how she came to
power in this almost entirely above land
society premature celebration we'd get a
little more of a head start yeah what's
up with that dude left well after huh
and it's not like they've been puttering
along toward the airport not to mention
he knew exactly where they were going
sure it makes sense that they'd make a
run for the launch pad but what if they
decided to lay low for a few days so
though a Tokyo Drift story
Danya Wilhelm in there I'm almost
positive I did so does that make it a
home he'll a will hum at this point that
I realized this has been a pretty low
speed chase for the last minute or so I
honestly haven't been this riveted since
that scene in Mitchell so it's the
Crimson doodle hop can happen love it
character says he won't allow something
to happen immediately before allowing
that exact thing to happen cliche hon
Paul mning the dice to the targaryen
here a hundred percent foretells that
she's coming back before the movie ends
because I saw the last Jedi goddamnit
also here's another sin for the last
Jedi just because I can several things
here first why wouldn't Moloch
immediately check the line for the
immigrants isn't that the only place Han
and cure could get through to escape
also there aren't even that many people
here like a quick swing around this tiny
terminal would easily turn up your
fugitives I'm not saying that I'm
rooting for Maalik to do this I'm just
saying it's stupid that he didn't
[Music]
convenient recruitment center is
massively convenient watch who you
people I'm also Rolo solos mouthy scooch
is all of the following a hilarious
insult a Canadian name for a yappy dog a
popular spicy Albanian Cola drink and
the name of my new aren't rated ska
revival band Cygnus soldier and kid you
know I farted not since Tim Meadows and
walk hard is someone sitting more
enticing and phony you don't want any
part of this line besides the
introduction of Beckett what does any
other bring to the table do we really
need several scenes of war footage and
strategy speeches I'll do whatever it
takes to get back to Corelli I've
already been away too long it's been
three years though right if Homs this
intent on going AWOL from the Empire is
this movie telling me he really hasn't
had a chance before now so up until now
Chewie was just eating all his cellmates
this dark little Ronny Howard dark han
survives this also they make it sound
like Chuy's a ravenous badass and of
course we know he can rip a fools arms
off if he wants so why I always playing
with his food he hasn't eaten in three
days
han should be all the dead right now I
guess it's kind of funny that Han
already speaks wookie but it sure does
create an easy escape for both of them
that is uber convenient
Wow good thing there are no troops
around this imperial ship that is
currently being held stolen nice
cinnamon and all but does this is the
first chance they've had to have this
conversation they made it all the way to
another planet and they just shared a
shower together that's a perfect place
to chat Chewbacca
har-har-har this movie could've been
great if you'd spent less time paying so
much lip service to the film's that came
before a nod here a handjob there it
gets to be obvious to the viewer and
therefore less enjoyable you might as
well have them turn to the camera and
tell the audience you love me I know a
whole future depends on this one school
and you bring in amateurs gotta side
with Val here why would Beckett bring in
amateurs for their one final score this
is like Danny Ocean bringing the actual
Bruce Willis into their heist in Ocean's
Twelve I waited a long time for a shot
like this I'm not about to screw it you
know I bet Hans palms are sweaty right
now his knees must also be weak since
he's sitting those arms definitely look
heavy and what's that on his sweater mom
spaghetti have you ever tried to
disinvite a wookie to anything damn it
Rio is one of the most fun characters in
this movie and I'm sending the fuck out
of it for killing his ass way too early
tell us about the girl Han is she nice
sharp teeth man Jon Favreau is discount
Steve Buscemi Inc so hard here I
literally had to check IMDB three times
to make certain it was Jon Favreau and
not Steve Buscemi huh what do you know
white men can jump why does it take
three individuals to do this on the
train they're essentially just tying
some cables down but no one wants to
help Val with a much more dangerous part
of the mission I'm just saying if they
didn't have Chewie and Han this would
have probably got much smoother fuel
what the hell there was no part of the
plan the Becket laid out earlier that
involved getting shot at by armed guards
also if there is a security presence on
this train why the hell are they all the
way back there isn't this the most
valuable compartment by far yeah go off
I looked it up
Chewie seven three and almost 112
kilograms which is Canadian for 250
pounds ain't no way Han is pulling him
back on the train with one King Han the
enemy soldiers have magnetic boots which
given the amount of ROM planning woody
and company did is something the high
screws should all be wearing as well
right on his first heist han has given
an opportunity to prove his piloting
skills what are the ping odds
kid you're half a pilot thanks for
telling me honestly nothing he's done so
far look remotely complicated but thanks
to your trained eye which I trust
because you also are a pilot
I now know he truly is a hell of a pilot
she just killed herself so the score
could carry on for money for her husband
and his crew she didn't think her life
was worth more than a score like
everyone in the crew would rather have
her live and they go on for another
score down the road but not her it's not
like her death is for the greater good
or anything this is an attempt to steal
for profit I'm sorry this death has no
emotional weight for me because it makes
no logical sense this movie suffers from
a common cinema fliction these days
last-second itis as though every bomb
exploding train derails airplane
crashing vehicle skidding toward a cliff
as the wall that utterly requires being
pushed to the very last second which it
does not tension does not require razor
edge margins of victory Galaxy Quest
made fun of this garbage writing almost
20 years ago
tin cup proof tense finales don't even
require protagonist victory as though
them pulling up the train car 200 yards
sooner and us watching the rest of the
cars fall to their deaths wouldn't have
been as thrilling or interesting and on
releases the payload anyway to aid their
escape making Tandy's sacrifice even
less meaningful than it already was and
it started out of zero Jesus if you
wanted woody to suffer loss and his lady
to die in a heroic way I can think of a
dozen better ways you could have written
it we were hired by crimson dawn isn't
that the group that hounds grooming
write about in Time magazine for me it's
worth the risk don't you this is the
quickest I've seen a civilian fully
commit to a life of crime since the
amazing yen in Ocean's eleven in this
movie's version of a rich crime lord
space-yacht penthouse we have a singer
with a bane pacifier and half a Shazam
themed lazy susan on her head beside one
of the more disgusting Ripley clone
fails form Alien Resurrection plus
thousands of sequence Paul Bettany now
having appeared in Star Wars and Marvel
movies is here by literally 30 percent
owned by Disney I work here as I've said
before space is really really big so
what are the odds han and kira find each
other on this pinata please someone with
an advanced mathematics degree show me
what the actual odds are this happening
and if you come back with an
interstellar type love answer I will
pink scream at you well that is
good news because you're going with him
this is weird suddenly he doesn't trust
someone so he sends Khaleesi on the
mission even though he also doesn't
fully trust her I know and I know just
where to find him boy this is some
geographical oddity isn't it not only
did the heist occur on Vandor one and
vas decided to bring his yacht to that
planet there's also very famous smuggler
with an incredibly fast ship on this
same planet within walking distance
charisma
not to mention his prodigious get it
it's not a cock joke thrown in the
middle of a Star Wars movie because I
think that was a cock joke thrown in the
middle of a Star Wars movie all we need
is his ship he'll never part with it
he loves that ship is there literally
only one ship in the entire universe
they can use for this caper if so maybe
the capers not worth the risk a freaking
bad odds from where I sit the seat taken
nobody's in the sink and I ain't taking
fun wow this might apply for a poker
game or at least this poker game but as
a general life rule this is some
terrible advice try this empty seats are
claimable bull with the director's chair
on a movie set or at the Masters or in
Buckingham Palace also movie takes
nearly an hour to land oh and that's
definitely a sip
anything han that's Han okay that's okay
this attempt to wreak on Billy Dee
Williams odd pronunciation of the name
the original trilogy makes me super
angry not everything we wondered about
needs a king explanation
god it's like modern movies want to
stamp out human imagination rather than
inspiring it oh great hands
way too much footage of this alien poker
game that ultimately means nothing since
no one knows how it's played I'll see
you mm and Oliver is splashing the pop
and I'm calling with what my ship
against your ship yeah but that's not
how calling works Han put his chips into
the pot which was on top of the 2000
dollar bet so if Lando calls with a ship
it's to cover the chips that are on the
table you move well making the Kessel
run this movie makes the Kessel run
sound famous
but then immediately points out how
impossible it is which means only a few
could have even tried it making me
wonder how I'd ever got famous other
than the mention in the original trilogy
of course I'm gonna need have to take
you don't even know how much the take is
though why speak in fractions before you
even know the total haul in dollars or
credits or whatever's
is that a g-spot joke thrown in the
middle of a Star Wars movie cuz I think
that was a g-spot joke there on in the
middle of a Star Wars movie and what if
I don't elect to go to camp oh please
don't start she said that and then he
waited hundreds of steps until they were
all the way outside on the ramp before
he responded with don't start can
Hollywood start coming up with less lazy
transitions so dialog doesn't get used
as sinew between unconnected shots I
actually would have a memory wiped but
she's got the best damn navigational
database in the galaxy it seems like the
Star Wars movies are littered with
people that are the best damn something
in the galaxy we've attached the homing
beacon
they won't elude us now yeah but they
didn't elude you before either right you
showed up to cut the train heist just in
time also how did in festoon or kalaxian
it's not like she was in the meeting
with us and even if she saw han and
Lando together there's no way she'd know
for sure what they were up to and dad
worked the line at the CC plan before he
got laid off he'll tease someone thought
han needed a personal connection to the
Millennium Falcon
so this dad got written and none of the
smart people on this production managed
to stop it before it got filmed and made
the final cut but this guy doesn't look
like Han or sound like Han but somehow
he still feels like huh and that is
enough it's kind of amazing I don't take
a cinema well you guys tear up or get
horny watching him passionately kissed
some not Princess Leia woman I'd like to
point out a more important issue which
is that these rods have nothing to keep
these hangers from sliding off someone
really wanted the hangers to have
unbroken circles at the top meaning we
needed closet rods with open ends but
then they stopped there and started
logic in the face and kicked it into the
fires of Mount Doom
am i interrupting something I hear this
move is called Mickey Knox blocking
cocked we had a good thing going here me
you Chewie Yeah right the makings of a
solid crew you just had two other crew
members killed in a failed heist asshole
assume everyone will betray you and
you'll never be disappointed
Jesus Christ can pick a telegraph he's
gonna eventually turn on Han any harder
during this trip you need anything equal
rights l3s quest for droid citizenship
is played for laughs here but we won't
be laughing when the robots start asking
for rights here in the real world
you'll be screaming screaming at the
latest horror film directed by a robot
as we scarf down a popcorn made by a
robot in a home theater made by robots
while a robot version of my college
girlfriend jerks off my robot
feelings for me sometimes I think it
works no seriously how the fuck does
that work god damn it movies dropping
all kinds of odds sex references here
with no follow-up simply because it
thinks the idea is funny I want to see
how that works
do not improvise saying this to Han Solo
in a movie named after him seems like
wasted breath and time for everyone
involved including me looking Dicer back
yet or even squeezing Lando's Return of
the Jedi helmet into this thing because
do all the nostalgia after rogue one I'm
not surprised but I am disappointed
three double sure the droids are taking
off their restraining bolts whatever
those are
how would that modify their programming
they're probably grateful but once
they're off they all turn into William
Wallace of course the alienvault guard
has an external set of sensitive sex
organs in the exact same place as a
human Jesus there are more crotchal
references in this movie that I
remembered you guys are not gonna
believe what I'm seeing up here you
better come take a look at this cliche
Chewbacca ex machina Chewbacca
so let's immediately start firing at
this large supply of a highly unstable
element l3 isn't gonna make it so Lando
goes in and Lando isn't gonna make it so
han goes in then han isn't gonna make it
so a wookie goes in this is like the
Russian nesting dolls of action scene
writing I'm legit surprised Chewie
didn't run into trouble and cause
Khaleesi to have to come out here - what
the hell those motherfuckers been this
whole time oh I know he's sad we're
supposed to be sad but I can't help but
think dude you've a robot that's whack
did you zakopane now watch Chewie die
inside for the next few seconds and you
can't make the Kessel run in less than
25 SEC's in parsecs
are they distance are they time you
don't know the entire Star Wars Canon
doesn't know this old trial is out of
order Attica Attica into the mouse room
man - without all three possible we can
download a brain into the Falcons
navicomputer right could we
theoretically yeah you got five seconds
to test that theory you time-wasting
arguing Dix also leave it to Han to
basically break the Kessel run record by
cheating he's the james t kirk of this
particular Kessel Oishi Maru
rationale on a KY line I don't know what
that means I'm telling you I don't know
what that means has become the cheap
modern comedic equivalent of did I do
that we need to divert auxiliary power
to the rear deflector shield because
we're now showing a Ron Han famously
bragged about making in record time
distance we're Rob here as viewers of
the chance to feel any tension for like
more than 10 fucking minutes the
characters feel tension but their paid
actors I know he makes it and does so in
record fashion so all these speed bumps
along the way or just red herrings she's
interfacing sponsorship now awesome so
all that talk a few minutes ago about
how difficult this would be it was
bullshit
alright let's took one cable in two
seconds buckle in now fans as we follow
Han again while he pilots the ship again
away from a sudden ginormous space alien
again again this movie has to new ideas
and everything else is just a call back
and homage or ripoff or an audience
applause break this goes Han for some
time this doesn't work he'll write a
raging sin boner and now the movie
subverted it by sacrifice oh that's the
stuff this works just did the Kessel run
in 12 parsecs great kid
don't get cocky I hate you goddamnit
this movie left no nostalgia stone
unturned and it's offensive
there were panels ripped off the fucking
Falcon when they were trying to fly it
out of the gravity well but the movie
saying emphasis aftermarket tracking
thingamajig stayed on and kept working
that entire time
okay nest and her crew end up being the
seeds of the rebellion which is a cool
twist enough what was with all that
threatening earlier in the movie they've
literally tried to kill Becket before
and did kill Rhea but now that Becket
has the co axiom we're just gonna have a
powwow really seems like they shoe horn
this rebel storyline in here heart I
need a drink
bring them inside this bartender should
be fired it's like three sips of alcohol
you just spilled on the table you ass
not this time
I'm leaving hang on is he pretending to
run like without the prophets or the co
axiom when Han actually believed this
why would Beckett even mention this
he knows Hans coming up to see Voss and
once the outcome to be certain death so
I say anything at all unless you're just
trying to cram another nostalgic
storyline reference it's not like Han is
just missing small signals of pending
betrayal and scum and villainy this is
right in his face oh I'm talking about
my other associate can you come in and
join us please don't I mean who the fuck
else was it gonna be and I'm also an
entrepreneur I mean you of all people
understand that a huge mistake what
about this situation got Beckett all
horned up to take the coaxial Evan
before the subterfuge everyone was
terrified of Dryden Voss and wouldn't
cross it now we're perfectly fine
stealing directly in front of him I
might mind you even if Han weren't
clouded by his boner shouldn't he get a
few more details are they meeting at the
refinery is she backing him up against
Beckett where are they getting a ship
I'm just saying a few more lines of
dialogue would make this villain turn a
little harder to predict Oh No it's
Darth Maul between him the force ghost
and Leia's Space Odyssey and last Jedi
there goes my ability to get it up for
any major characters death in this
franchise Kira
you've and I will be working much more
closely from now on I don't know about
that dude did you see the box office
numbers for this thing I hope you're
still paying attention because now I'm
gonna tell you the most important movie
takes a firm stance on whether or not
Hahn is the type to shoot first you fold
now you walk away with enough to get
yourself your own little ship you call
I'm gonna clean you out again movie does
give us a little more Orlando which is
always welcome but this ending feels
more tacked on than the jiho sequence at
the end of Slumdog Millionaire that kid
said he heard about this very big
gangster putting together a job yeah
damn it we're cramming Java into this
story too everything important in Hans
life happened within a week you don't
want no part of this what company do you
none of your business company so crazy
someplace else
we're all stocked up here okay sometimes
a lot of times I think I appreciate your
eyes you're real straight-shooter
it's no big deal yeah then why'd you do
it
that's why baby are you using my babies
now